[Musique]
la fête de la musique mais aussi le
premier jour de l'été à voisins le
bretonneux groupes locaux associations
de la ville et formations se sont
succédé sur une scène ouverte aux
jardins eugène fleuret malheureusement
la pluie s'est invitée et à abréger la
soirée et des orages se sont abattus sur
les yvelines ah oui des dizaines de
caves de particuliers de commerces ont
été inondés plus d'un mètre pour
certains aucun blessé n'est à déplorer
près de 500 élèves des douze communes de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se sont retrouvés à l'occasion
d'une journée olympique au golf national
ce mercredi 23 juin à l'occasion de
faire des découvertes sportives ou de
rencontrer des athlètes de haut niveau
une vingtaine d'étudiants de l'école
aisé au pari vélizy ont présenté leur
projet d'entrepreneuriat dans le cadre
d'un forum industriel
l'établissement est spécialisée dans la
formation d'ingénieurs pendant cette
journée ils ont rencontré des
représentants d'entreprises et des
institutionnels
enfin les élèves élan courtois de cm2
passante au collège ont pu profiter
d'une traditionnelle cérémonie organisée
par la commune coli des jauges oblige
cinq soirées ont été organisées entre le
14 et le 22 juin pour célébrer ses 400
élèves et discours applaudissements et
remise de cadeau pour fêter ce passage
importante dans une scolarité
[Musique]